[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le travail c'est la santé rien faire
c'est la concerne bienvenue dans ces
idées qui gouvernent le monde nous
allons vous parler de la remise en cause
du travail la chanson d'Henri Salvador
dont vous venez d'écouter le fameux
refrain si populaire à la fin des années
60 à l'actualité d'une femme de la
Fontaine c'est dire si elle exprime une
vérité passée mais qui demeure
contemporaine en témoigne la vivacité
critique à l'égard du prolongement de
l'âge de la retraite tant le rapport au
travail a changé dans nos sociétés de
consommation et de loisirs première
clarification la dimension
anthropologique du travail recouvre des
potentialités sociales distinctes entre
le salariat les travailleurs
indépendants les professions libérales
des agriculteurs les ouvriers etc à cela
s'ajoute la modification des conditions
de travail la matérialisation due au
télétravail l'automatisation des tâches
les nouveaux modes d'organisation ou
travail et non travail ce chevauchent il
n'est pas il n'est plus aisé de définir
une identité sociale et professionnelle
du travail parce que la valeur
émancipatrice est progressiste du
travail fait concurrence
un nouvel art de vivre plus
individualisé et qui place la vraie vie
sans qu'on sache ce qu'elle cette
expression hédoniste signifie et recèle
avant le travail de tout cela nous
allons vous parler avec mes invités que
je vous présente
Clara Gemma vous êtes dirigeant
d'entreprise et vous êtes co-fondatrice
de race vous nous direz ce que race à la
ville meurt vous êtes économiste et
directeur de la Charte tdte transition
démographique transition économique
Jean-Claude Mahy vous êtes ancien
secrétaire général de Force ouvrières et
Nicolas Meyer Rossignol que nous avons
avec nous et que je remercie en
visioconférence qui est maire de Rouen
président de la métropole et vous êtes
également premier secrétaire délégué du
Parti socialiste
[Musique]
alors vous venez de voir cette citation
d'Éric Chiotti je suis là de ce bashing
permanent du travail et de cet éloge de
la paresse portée par l'extrême gauche
on est en plein dans l'actualité
derrière la réforme des retraites qui a
fait l'objet d'une procédure de 49-3 et
l'émotion de censure qui ont été
rejetées la réflexion s'orient désormais
sur le travail ce qu'il en est ce qu'il
sera quel lien faites-vous entre la
question des retraites et la remise en
cause du travail Jean-Claude Mahe la
seule question je crois qu'il faut se
poser c'est pourquoi des salariés si
l'on parle des salariés ne veulent pas
travailler plus longtemps quelles sont
les raisons qu'ils font qu'ils ne
veulent pas travailler plus longtemps
c'est alors il y a des questions de
pénibilité pénibilité physique le
question de qui ne se sentent mal dans
leur peau qui sont moins bien rémunérés
en fait il y a des gens qui sont prêts à
travers le plus longtemps sans que ça
pose de problème le problème c'est et
c'est ce qui sont les plus percutés par
le projet de réforme du gouvernement à
savoir les populations les moins
qualifiées et aussi ce qu'on appelle les
catégories catégories intermédiaires
classement moyenne quoi ce sont là qui
ont enfin difficultés dans leur relation
dans leur relation de travail ils
expriment de de nouvelles inspirations
différentes et puis le aussi je pense
que la crise pandémique a transformé
certaines choses le développement par
exemple du travail mais le télétravail
ne concerne pas tout le monde je crois
que c'est un économiste Bruno pallier
qui fait la distinction entre les
cerveaux et les servants les servants
étant ceux qu'on a appelé les essentiels
pendant la crise sanitaire ceux qui ne
pouvaient pas télétravailler les
livreurs les caissières etc et c'est
cela qui en plus sont les moins payés
donc ça pose un problème à la fois de
politique globale vis-à-vis du travail
et de l'évolution en tant que telle du
rapport au travail alors Clara Gaymard
des liens vous voyez vous dans le
malaise social et la question du travail
je pense que le malaise il est beaucoup
plus profond que simplement l'approche
du travail c'est la question de sens
c'est quel sens on donne à sa vie
quelle priorité on donne à sa vie et
c'est vrai que tout le cheminement qu'on
a eu depuis les années 70 avec
la standardisation la mondialisation le
fait que dans les grandes entreprises on
est fait des des fonctionnements
transversaux dans le jargon on appelle
ça matricielle à la fois donner le
sentiment que les gens étaient
remplaçables changeables
interchangeables c'est ce qu'a très bien
expliqué Cydia Fleury et que finalement
la matrice était peut-être était plus
importante que les personnes et ce qui
me semble essentiel c'est aujourd'hui on
le voit nous dans la vitalité des
startups dans la vitalité des jeunes
entreprises dans la visibilité du métier
qu'on fait puisque nous-mêmes nous
sommes les investisseurs avec mon ZAC de
binaire on a créé une société
d'investissement qui investit dans les
entreprises en croissance et nous
donnons 50% de ce que nous gagnons à une
fondation pour aider les entrepreneurs
donc on a la chance d'être dans le
vivier
qui fournit et qui est créatif mais tous
toutes les personnes hommes et femmes
qui sont entrepreneurs ils cherchent à
construire du sens et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il
se développe énormément sur des sujets
sur la biodiversité le changement
climatique etc je voudrais vous poser
une petite question personnelle Clara
Gemma vous avez dirigé une très grande
entreprise et aujourd'hui vous êtes dans
une petite entreprise est-ce que c'est
par rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
que vous avez quitté ce grand machin
pour quelque chose de plus humain et qui
a plus de sens que le
c'est pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que moi j'avais envie d'aider mon
pays
c'était un moment où il y avait beaucoup
de French machine où il y avait cet
article de Libération qui disait jeunes
de France bariez-vous l'avenir est
ailleurs et avec mon associé mon sac de
binières on s'est dit ben nous on a eu
la chance de réussir grâce à la France
moi d'autant plus que je suis une femme
et que j'ai eu beaucoup d'enfants et
donc j'étais un pays qui m'a permis de
travailler et d'être et d'être père de
famille ce qui n'est pas vrai ni en
Allemagne ni en Espagne enfin dans les
pays voisins et on s'est dit qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour aider notre pays
et on a voulu créer quelque chose qui
permettait d'accompagner ceux qui créent
des emplois c'est-à-dire les jeunes
entrepreneurs et donc on a créé une
société d'investissement qui nous permet
d'investir dans les entreprises et le
fait que on donne la moitié de ce qu'on
gagne à des jeunes entrepreneurs de
crise viviers donc c'était plutôt l'idée
de se dire comment nous on peut
participer au fait que les gens non
seulement il est de la création
d'emplois mais d'emploi dont les gens
sont pour lesquels les gens sont heureux
de travailler nous on a aujourd'hui on a
démarré à deux aujourd'hui on a 90
vous avez quitté quand je voudrais juste
te dire une chose importante c'est que
on est à parité totale et quand on a
démarré les gens nous ont dit mais qui
vous allez recruter qui va donner 50% de
ce qui gagne et aujourd'hui on est 90 on
a démontré que la générosité était un
moteur économique et les gens viennent
chez nous justement parce que nous
sommes porteurs de sens vous avez quitté
la général électrique en Général
Electric en 2016 alors Nicolas meilleur
Rossignol vous avez entendu parler de
manque de sens du travail vous qui êtes
à la tête ou à j'allais dire en
collaboration d'un parti important le
Parti socialiste est-ce que vous
constatez que le travail manque de sens
aujourd'hui et que et quel lien vous
faites entre l'agitation sociale liée à
la réforme des retraites et la question
du travail
d'abord si vous permettez de
corriger un point je parlerai pas
d'agitation sociale c'est une
protestation qui de mon point de vue est
parfaitement légitime c'est pas une
agitation mais je referme la parenthèse
sur le travail oui à la question du sens
pour moi je dirais que les
particulièrement depuis la crise covid
et on le voit aussi dans la crise qu'on
vit en ce moment sur les retraites il y
a trois mots clés qui me frappent
il y a d'abord la question de la
soutenabilité au travail ce que dit
notamment Dominique mesdames et c'est un
sujet de débat qui qui convoque de
nombreux intellectuels on le voit à
travers le débat sur la pénibilité par
exemple et plus largement
comment est-ce qu'on peut accepter de
continuer d'exercer des métiers qui pour
certains sont reconnus comme pénibles
pour d'autres ne le sont pas alors que
plus personne veut y aller je pense par
exemple à l'hôpital public
[Musique]
vers des métiers des travaux qui est du
travail qui a plus de sens et puis il y
a une troisième notion que pour ma part
je me garderai bien de définir mais qui
est une certaine façon le bonheur au
travail ou les mains aussi passion au
travail c'est-à-dire comment est-ce
qu'on s'épanouit dans le travail par le
travail alors évidemment pour les
socialistes et pas que pour les
socialistes il y a la question du temps
de travail mais il n'y a pas que ça il y
a aussi par exemple la représentation
des salariés dans l'entreprise dans la
gouvernance de l'entreprise ça aussi
c'est une forme d'émancipation et
d'épanouissement je dirais qu'il y a la
question des de la valorisation des
métiers et de l'utilité sociale
écologique des métiers parce qu'on voit
qu'avec l'évolution du monde certains
métiers sont de vrais probablement être
plus valorisés qu'ils ne le sont tout à
l'heure parler des des métiers de
diessentiel et les autres est-ce que la
culture c'est moins essentiel que le
reste pas absolument certain quand même
je crois même tout à fait le contraire
et on voit aussi que par rapport à la
transition écologique il y a des métiers
et peut-être aussi des nouveaux métiers
qui sont de plus en plus essentiel pour
le coup et en tout cas mal valorisé dans
notre dans notre société donc je veux
pas être trop long mais
l'insoutenabilité l'insoutenabilité de
métier et du travail c'est clairement un
sujet qui pour l'instant n'est pas
suffisamment travaillé ou si je peux me
permettre ce jeu de mots
le sens et la recherche de sens du
travail et ça c'est pour moi quelque
chose d'intéressant parce que c'est une
façon de rassembler des forces pas que
public mais public et privées et
citoyenne vers un même objectif par
exemple celui de la transition sociale
écologique et puis enfin effectivement
cette question si difficile de de
bonheur et d'émancipation par le travail
je dis qu'elle est assez difficile parce
que
elle réclame aussi un projet politique
et elle pose la question de la place
notamment des entreprises pas uniquement
mais notamment les entreprises sociétés
monsieur meilleur Rossignol mais notre
émission n'est pas sur les retraites
mais sur le travail mais vous êtes un
responsable politique important
très brièvement
au malaise social actuel
quel
issue vous verriez
pour que la tension baisse
brièvement parce que le sujet la le sens
du travail
je vais vous répondre par deux syllabes
bon alors puisque vous restez sur le
retrait je vais demander à Monsieur
Wilmer cette question démographique que
vous connaissez bien est-ce que elle
plombe le régime des retraites
et
comment on peut faire le lien avec la
question du travail
alors effectivement
la population française vieillit c'est
un phénomène qui existe depuis plus de
10 ans et ce qui veut dire très
concrètement qu'il y a de plus en plus
de personnes de plus de 60 ans il y a de
plus en plus de retraités
en même temps il y a de moins en moins
de jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail mais alors ce qui est tout à
fait bénéfique c'est qu'il y a de plus
en plus de gens qui travaillent ce qu'on
ne notre avis ce qu'on n'a pas dit assez
c'est que depuis 7 à 10 ans il y a de
plus en plus de jeunes qui travaillent
il y a de plus en plus de seniors qui
travaillent
et que tout ça et très positif mais il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'effectivement
on peut il est évident qu'il y aura un
problème de financement des retraites
dans les 10 prochaines années même si
actuellement il y a pas un déficit très
important et il va de soi que ce défi il
y aura un déficit alors il y a des
estimations de 10 15 milliards dans les
10 ans donc c'est pour ça que en tant
que économiste moi je pense que là il
fallait faire une réforme des retraites
et l'argument financier vous paraît
consolider
la nécessité d'une réforme
à savoir que le la France est très
endettée la hausse des taux d'intérêt
aidants il y a besoin d'avoir une
cagnotte ce d'ailleurs ce qu'on
reprochait les syndicats non il y a
besoin dans les 10 ans qui viennent
effectivement d'assurer le financement
des retraites si on veut pas baisser des
retraites dans les 10 10 15 ans qui
viennent il faut face à cette vague
démographique
face au vieillissement de la population
il faut effectivement
faire une réforme des retraites alors
c'est pas pour ça que je pense qu'il
fallait faire cette réforme
c'est du côté on avait pris position du
côté de la chair transition
démographique transition économique pour
une réforme des retraites il y a plus
d'un an qui mettent au départ la
réflexion et le débat sur les le travail
et les conditions de travail avant de
faire cette réforme des retraites et on
avait effectivement souligné
l'importance l'importance de réfléchir
sur les conditions de travail
l'importance de la formation des seniors
par exemple qui est absolument
insuffisante en France bref ça on avait
mis le doigt sur l'importance d'un débat
sur les
le travail et donc je trouve que de ce
point de vue là
bon les pouvoirs publics semblent
s'engager dans une réflexion maintenant
sur le conditions de travail sur la
formation et ça me paraît une excellente
chose Monsieur Mailly peut-être dire
quelque chose oui mais ça ce que je veux
dire je pense pas que enfin quand on
regarde le sur les marchés financiers je
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui les principales
inquiét des marchés financiers ce soit
la réforme des retraites en France quoi
bon si on regarde la différence de taux
d'intérêt à disons entre par exemple
pour la France et l'Allemagne c'est je
crois 015 ou 0,20 point de base c'est
pas grand chose
financière globale que ça bon et je
pense d'ailleurs que depuis le début
tous les arguments utilisés par le
gouvernement du manière sont tombées à
l'eau c'est juste bah non tout le monde
a prouvé que c'était pas une réforme
juste après c'est pour financer la santé
ou l'école mais ce qui va aux retraites
ne doit pas financer la santé l'école
enfin tous les arguments ont été
démontées d'une certaine manière alors
si effectivement à terme moi je ne
conteste pas qu'à terme alors après pas
30 ans les prévisions à 30 ans donc gare
de sens mais si à terme il y a des
problèmes financiers il faut regarder
ces problèmes financiers mais il y a
d'autres moyens pour régler ces
problèmes financiers que de reculer
l'âge autoritairement quand même
rappeler une chose qu'on me souligne pas
assez on dit dans d'autres pays là je la
retraite est plus tardive oui mais si on
présente les choses autrement pour la
France quel est l'âge en France que l'on
peut prendre sa retraite à taux plein
c'est 67 ans ne l'oublions pas et si on
a tout notre trimestre et 62 ans on peut
partir en Allemagne c'est 65 ans mais on
peut partir à partir de 63 ans avec au
moins 35 ans de cotisations avec une
décote à ce moment-là donc voilà c'est
pas la raison vous savez on va revenir
sur la question du travail alors
Monsieur Meyer Rossignol il n'y a pas
qu'Eric Ciotti patron des républicains
pour défendre le travail Fabien Roussel
du Parti communiste a pu dire la gauche
doit défendre le travail et ne pas être
la gauche des allocations et des minimas
sociaux à quoi Sandrine Rousseau a
rétorqué la valeur travail est
clairement une valeur de la droite où
vous situez-vous sur la valeur travail
monsieur Meyer rossignol
par rapport à ce climat à cette ce
clivage idéologique
oui enfin je sais pas si c'est un
clivage idéologique ou si c'est une
battle de punchline en bon français
parce que là on est plutôt dans ce
registre franchement
d'abord les cotisations
c'est un salaire différé donc c'est un
choix politique ne permettre à une
société et aux uns et aux autres dans
cette société et ben de
d'avoir une partie de son salaire
prélevé pour pouvoir en profiter plus
tard ou à d'autres moments dans sa vie
quand c'est plus difficile plus pénible
pour des raisons de santé de vieillesse
de prévoyance etc donc franchement
si c'est ça
un mauvais choix bah non moi je l'assume
mais alors évidemment après il y a des
questions de curseur à quel niveau de
cotisation qu'elles vont bien sûr enfin
le principe d'avoir une forme de
solidarité et je pense qu'il est pas
contesté par la gauche ensuite sur la
question la valeur travail là il me
semble qu'il y a un faux débat
si si on veut être un peu provocateur le
travail en soi n'est pas n'est pas une
valeur il peut être
le goût de l'effort peut être une valeur
mais le travail en tant que tel c'est un
facteur c'est un facteur de quoi un
facteur d'émancipation facteur de
libération d'émancipation individuelle
pour la classe ouvrière dans des raisons
historiques et aujourd'hui d'une façon
aussi de valoriser la dignité humaine
par la qualité du travail rendu par
exemple les agents des services publics
par exemple les infirmiers les
infirmières par exemple les premiers
corvées comme on a dit pendant la
pandémie donc en fait la vraie question
qui est derrière c'est pas à mon avis
les pour ou contre le travail la France
qui se lève tôt et les autres là ça me
paraît très manichéen comme débat en
revanche je crois que c'est en tout cas
ce que revendique la gauche et est-ce
que revendique les socialistes c'est de
quelle façon notre société dans le dans
le projet politique qu'elle porte et
quand je dis notre société c'est pas
uniquement la société française et je
dirais plutôt la Société européenne de
quelle façon nous valorisons ce qui fait
du sens qu'elle l'utilité j'aime bien
cette expression l'utilité sociale éc
logique des métiers et du travail et qui
est derrière
monsieur Meyer Rossignol je voudrais
quand même que vous précisiez votre
pensée
au niveau d'un diagnostic politique
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ceux qui
disent que les milieux ouvriers et
populaires ce sont sentis trahis par une
partie de l'idéologie de gauche sur la
fin du travail et abandonné par la
gauche sont allés rejoindre l'extrême
droite
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui
existe et en plus ça devrait vous parler
parce que vous avez aussi j'allais dire
une carrière de d'ingénieur et de très
haut niveau est-ce que vous constatez ce
vous faites ce diagnostic là
parce que ce que ce que l'on constate
moi je suis maire de Rouen en roue c'est
une ville populaire c'est une ville
industrielle une vie portuaire et comme
une bonne partie du Nord-Ouest de la
France comme la somme je rappelle
toujours que Hénin-Beaumont qui est
connu malheureusement aujourd'hui pour
être un des bastions du du rassemblement
national c'est juste à côté de
Noyelles-Godault qui est la patrie ou le
village natal si je dis pas de bêtises
de Maurice Thorez de la CGT donc
effectivement dans notamment cette
partie de la France qu'est-ce qu'on voit
bien on voit que il y a une forme de
comment dire de
désenchantement de désillusion de
violence de colère effectivement de
d'ouvriers de catégories dites
populaires et moi je le vois très bien à
Rouen qui ont eu le sentiment d'abord
d'avoir été abandonnés dans la
mondialisation chez moi c'est la
raffinerie Pétroplus qui ferme parce
qu'on va faire ouvrir des raffineries
ailleurs sont des usines qui ferment
c'est la désindustrialisation c'est la
perte de et puis pour reprendre le mot
de Bruno Latour d'être des migrants de
l'intérieur c'est à dire que le pays les
abandonne de l'intérieur c'est à dire
que tout d'un coup là où ils habitent
ben il y a plus de maternité on peut
plus accoucher proche de chez soi il y a
plus de poste il y a plus de service
public il y a plus de train il y a plus
voilà bon donc oui il y a une forme de
de sentiment d'abandon à la fois
européen et nationale l'Europe devenant
un problème plus qu'une solution etc etc
et c'est vrai rien de la cacher
là-dessus je pense qu'on a tous notre
part de responsabilité à gauche
là-dessus et notamment les socialistes
sur retravailler et reproposer une offre
réellement populaire sur le pouvoir de
vivre en réalité c'est à dire sur la
protection des catégories sociales qui
vivent et qui veulent vivre dignement de
leur travail et de ce point de vue là
c'est vrai notamment dans les années 90
2000 la gauche a pu se perdre un peu et
singulièrement les socialistes ceci dit
franchement on en est revenu largement
et aujourd'hui dans l'offre politique à
gauche en général et socialiste en
particulier vous allez trouver notamment
sur la question sociale écologique sur
le bouclier social écologique sur les
nouveaux services publics
dans les territoires dit ruraux ou comme
on appelle malheureusement périphérique
des propositions très concrètes qui vont
dans ce sens là mais c'est un travail de
très longue haleine et et franchement ça
va ça va prendre du temps bien entendu
merci majeur parce que parce que le pays
est clivé là-dessus merci au niveau
européen alors Clara Gaymard sur cette
utopie de la fin du travail c'est
quelque chose que qu'on constate en
France et aussi à l'étranger parce que
avec votre carrière de dirigeante vous
avez pu côtoyer l'étranger vous avez
rappelé vous-même que vous avez un lien
avec l'étranger oui alors j'ai un lien
avec l'étranger donc j'ai une carrière
internationale qui m'a permis de voyager
et de travailler avec beaucoup de
nationalités différentes on parle
beaucoup du désenchantement du
de la du refus du travail en fait je
pense que le sujet est très différent de
ce qu'on dit parce que quand si tu
regardes on cite beaucoup les jeunes de
la gros qui ont pas voulu prendre de
rendre classement et ne pas rentrer dans
des grands groupes internationaux quand
ils disent que et en caricaturant on
imagine qu'ils veulent aller sur le
plateau du Larzac élevé des chèvres il y
a pas de métier plus fatigant que d'être
que d'être berger c'est 70 heures par
semaine c'est pas les 35 heures
au fond ce qu'il y a dans la jeunesse et
on voit aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes qui ne veulent plus être salariés
ils veulent être soit entrepreneur soit
intermittents du spectacle soit sur des
métiers où ils sont libres de leur choix
de ce pourquoi et pour qui ils veulent
travailler donc il y a une contestation
du salariat tel qu'on l'a conçu et
construit en France parce qu'on a fait
du salariat l'espèce de modèle clé qui
fait que c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut
avoir après c'est grâce à ça qu'on peut
avoir une place dans la société et on
voit aujourd'hui émerger de nouvelles
formes de travail
qui correspondent à leur aspirations
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure du
bonheur ou de l'accomplissement et
aujourd'hui les jeunes ils veulent ils
ont beaucoup ne peuvent pas accepter de
travailler pour quelque chose qui nous
disons sentiment que ça va abîmer encore
plus la planète abîmée encore plus la
biodiversité et ils cherchent au-delà du
sens personnel ils ont moi ce qui me
frappe dans la Genèse aujourd'hui quand
je parle de la jeunesse je pense que ça
touche en fait toutes les générations on
voit bien l'émergence des supers bio etc
les gens qui veulent manger bien qui
veulent repenser leur façon de vivre
moins consommer consommer français
consommer plus intelligemment c'est
vraiment une remise en cause d'une
société qui nous a un peu à bêtises
d'une société de consommation tous
azimute toujours plus toujours plus
toujours plus et avec l'idée que c'est
pas en ayant les plaques placards plein
qu'on est plus heureux mais c'est en
accomplissant un travail qui a du sens
et
qui est bien payé et c'est tout le sujet
de notre société c'est qu'elle ne sait
pas aujourd'hui payer au juste prix ceux
qui apportent il a très bien dit apporte
une vraie force vive nécessaire à au
pays on peut parler des agriculteurs on
a parlé des infirmières on a parlé tout
ça et le je suis d'accord avec vous que
ce serait intéressant d'avoir un sujet
sur la c'est quoi le travail c'est quoi
la contribution à la société puisque on
est tous foutu pareil on est très
différent mais on a envie de réussir et
on a envie de partager la réussite on
est tous on a envie de transmettre
à nos enfants à ceux qu'on à ce qu'on
aime etc et donc de repenser d'arrêter
de penser qu'il y a que le salariat et
qu'il y a d'autres formes d'expression
du travail c'est exactement cette
révolution qui est en train de se dire
merci alors Alain Wilmer vous êtes deux
cultures
sur le travail entre les générations
entre les
mais je voudrais revenir quand même sur
effectivement le travail et le fait que
les Français travaillent de plus en plus
il faut quand même pas l'oublier c'est à
dire que depuis donc 10 ans en gros il y
a 500 000 jeunes qui travaillent de 20 à
30 ans qui travaille en plus il y avait
il y a 10 ans il y a un million 300000
seniors qui travaillent
et ça contribue à la réduction du
chômage on est quand même été pendant
depuis les années 80-90 dans une culture
finalement de la fatalité du chômage et
le chômage est descendu de 10% à environ
7%. donc je crois que il y a eu tout un
débat sur le travail depuis deux mois
sur une étude liée à une étude de
l'ifope et de et de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès qui prétendait que il y aurait
une épidémie de flemme
les Français seraient-ils devenus
flemmard je crois que la réalité
s'inscrit en faux il n'y a pas de
flemmard il n'y a pas de flemme chez les
Français au contraire il plébiscite le
travail depuis de 10 ans alors
maintenant je crois que le travail
surtout au travers des jeunes
générations est en train d'évoluer ils
ont de nouvelles exigences ce qui a été
rappelé ils veulent plus de sens au
travail ils veulent que ça soit
conciliable avec les conditions de vie
sociale familiales et je crois que c'est
le défi qui est devant nous et ça me
semble tout à fait justifié
[Musique]
vous venez de voir ce que dit
Jean-Pierre Le goffre la société de
consommation et de loisirs à bouleverser
le rapport au travail
monsieur Mailly l'importance du temps
libre comme l'épanouissement personnel
contribue à établir une nouvelle
hiérarchie des activités sociales à
votre avis est-ce que cette nouvelle
hiérarchie elle est perçue de la même
manière par l'ensemble du monde du
travail
non enfin écoutez moi quand on a ce
Sandrine Rousseau car sorti le droit à
la paresse bon je pense que c'était une
forme de provocation quoi parce que
ressortir je rappelle que le droit
d'apparaisse formule de Paul lafargne
c'était au moment du fin du 19e ou les
syndicats réclamaient les trois vitres à
8h de travail 8h de loisirs 8 heures de
repos on en est loin donc non non le
travail est une activité importante pour
l'individu quel qu'il soit c'est alors
après il faut qu'il puisse y prendre un
plaisir d'une certaine manière qu'ils se
sont utiles voir qu'il s'émancipe voilà
c'est ça qui est important après qu'il y
ait rappelez-vous
Kens expliquer que on travaillerait tous
30 heures etc et de moins en moins bon
compte tenu des évolutions du pauvre bon
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais on a
quand même globalement une durée du
travail partout pas qu'en France qui a
diminué en durée de bon permis par les
gains de productivité permis par toute
une source ce qui permet d'avoir
plus de plus de temps libre mais ce qui
change beaucoup en ce moment c'est
qu'effectivement si on prend par exemple
un seul exemple c'est celui du
télétravail avec le télétravail qui
s'est fortement développé il y a un
repositionnement vie publique vie privée
etc et ça avait voulu
ça en général les entreprises c'est
entre 1 2 3 jours de télétravail qui
sont accordés ça dépend ça dépend des
entreprises et dernier point qui m'a
paraît également important oui il y a
c'est une partie de de des plus jeunes
recherches pas de salariat ils veulent
être freelance bon mais le problème
c'est être freelance mais pouvoir avoir
aussi accès à une protection sociale
être payé correctement parce que quand
vous êtes salarié vous êtes qu'on
appelle l'emploi du travail la
subordination juridique mais vous avez
beaucoup de jeunes etc qui sont
travaillés pour des plateformes qui sont
en subordination économique qui n'ont
pas droit à une protection sociale qui
donc voilà donc c'est ça qu'il faut
travailler mais cette quête d'autonomie
mais y compris pour les salariés
beaucoup de salariés considèrent
aujourd'hui enfin Clara Gaimard
l'expliquait tout à l'heure les
nouvelles modes de gestion de management
dans les entreprises voudraient avoir
plus d'autonomie dans leur travail ce
qui n'est pas le cas et ça c'est une
demande aussi chez les salariés oui
monsieur Wilmer il y a une question
qu'on pourrait évoquer avec
l'informatisation des tâches
les nouvelles pratiques managériales
comme l'informatisation des tâches sont
remises en cause au cours d'une émission
ici l'économiste Daniel Cohen a démonté
en quelque sorte l'informatisation des
tâches en disant que sa portée atteinte
aux relations sociales
vous êtes d'accord avec ça
je serai plus partagé si vous voulez
l'informatisation c'est quand même ça
engendre des bénéfices exceptionnels on
en bénéficie tous dans le surplan
communication etc ça engendre pour les
économistes aussi un effet de
polarisation du marché du travail vous
avez de plus en plus de gens qualifiés
qui sont demandés par les entreprises et
vous avez aussi de plus en plus de gens
peu qualifiés qui sont également
demandés donc ça ça pose un redoutable
problème c'est que la classe moyenne en
gros les compétences moyennes sont en
train de diminuer et ça provoque un
ressentiment je pense important dans ces
catégories donc
au delà du problème effectivement de
l'autonomie grâce à l'informatisation il
faut prendre en compte cette dimension
de l'informatisation d'une manière
générale de l'arrivée des nouvelles
technologies qui modifient complètement
les relations de travail qui modifient
les catégories qui en profitent les plus
qualifiés celle qui est en souffrent et
les moins qualifiés
sur ce point
faut se méfier des calculs un peu
définitifs et simpliste moi je me
souviens qu'il y a quelques années avec
l'émergence de la digitalisation on
disait que ça allait supprimer au moins
300000 ou peut-être 500 000 emplois en
France dans les banques etc et que le
chômage elle a explosé en fait c'est
tout le contraire qui était en train de
se produire on n'a jamais eu autant
d'emplois disponibles aujourd'hui en
France mais on parle de la qualité de la
relation sociale on n'est pas
je voulais simplement dire que on avait
ce stateman si je puis dire cette
affirmation que la digitalisation allait
créer le chômage et maintenant on a
cette affirmation que la digitalisation
allait bien sûr ça change la façon dont
on travaille mais c'est toujours la même
chose
ça en même temps ça facilite
considérablement la tâche ça permet
d'ailleurs le télétravail ça permet aux
gens dans comme l'a dit Monsieur Bailly
Jean-Claude Bailly nous dans notre
entreprise on on a deux jours de
télétravail dans l'entreprise c'est très
très apprécié des jeunes je peux vous le
dire et pas seulement ça donne une ça
offre une des potentialités incroyables
et surtout ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que la on a plus loin plus loin de
l'informatisation maintenant on est dans
la diptèque on est dans la technologie
qui est rapportée qui rapportait à
l'industrie je veux juste donner un
exemple nous on accompagne des startups
on a pas enseigné
en décrire beaucoup mais grâce à l'image
satellite grâce à
au drone et grâce à l'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui on arrive à
mesurer et à quantifier quand on
replante des sols dans les endroits
miniers sur les bords des routes etc et
donc recalculer la prestation la
biodiversité etc ça c'est des c'est des
trucs qui coûtent pas cher alors que
avant ça demandait une armée de gens il
qu'ils aillent semer eux-mêmes
maintenant on s'aime avec des drones etc
donc il faut pas voir que c'est
simplement d'être derrière un ordinateur
ça va toucher ça touche toute
l'industrie aujourd'hui comme on a quand
on arrive à faire des jumeaux numériques
dans les entreprises qui permettent de
savoir très exactement où se trouve tel
tuyau comment il faut le changer comment
il faut le réparer etc ça fait des
économies de de maintenant de complexité
etc énorme donc
la technologie elle apporte évidemment
un bienfait qui fait que on peut faire
moins de tâches répétitives etc
maintenant après tout est toujours tout
est toujours dans la façon dont on
gouverne l'entreprise quelle
responsabilité on a vis-à-vis de ses
salariés quand on parle de données du
sens à l'entreprise c'est aussi la façon
dont on célèbre les réussites dont on
partage la réussite partage on partage
la valeur dans la manière dont on
reconnaît l'importance et justement lire
en place
remplacabilité de chaque individu parce
que la fonction elle est elle est
interchangeable mais chaque individu va
l'exercer d'une façon différente et
c'est donc ce retour à la place
essentielle de la personne dans
l'entreprise monsieur meilleur Rossignol
vous pourrez peut-être dire un mot sur
l'informatisation du travail mais je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur une
enquête de l'institut Montaigne
concernant la satisfaction au travail
une récente enquête les résultats sont
plutôt optimistes mais dès lors que cela
concerne les salaires en bas de
l'échelle ou moindre ou de moindre
qualification ça n'est pas le cas est-ce
que vous craignez que à ce niveau
c'est-à-dire là où il y a l'acné en
quelque sorte de la contestation sociale
on aille vers un travail à deux vitesses
on classe les les sous qualifiés les
surqualifiés est-ce qu'on va vers ça
aujourd'hui avec une responsabilité de
l'informatisation si je puis dire comme
accès plus
facile au travail
oui c'est intéressant votre question
parce que je voudrais faire un lien on
va essayer de faire un lien entre
effectivement cette étude de l'Institut
Montaigne et le petit échange qui a eu
juste précédemment sur le numérique et
puis l'évolution de au moins de certains
types de métiers et du travail dans
plutôt les fonctions tertiaires et les
créations de valeur notamment dans liées
aux gammes productivité et puis plus
largement à l'informatique aux
technologies d'information de la
communication en fait
sans être trop négatif ce qu'on constate
sur le terrain et en particulier sur des
des villes comme comme celle que j'ai le
l'honneur d'administrer comme Rouen
c'est que vous avez une forme
d'accroissement des
inégalités symboliques du travail je
m'explique vous avez d'un côté ce qui a
été dit tout à l'heure des métiers
tertiarisés de plus en plus numérisée
mondialisé bien payé moins pénible en
tout cas sur les pénibilités classiques
physiques parce qu'il y a d'autres
sujets quand même
la laisse électronique je passe
plutôt bien valorisé dans notre société
bon et puis de l'autre côté avec du
télétravail donc avec des évolutions
plutôt perçues en général positivement
et de l'autre côté c'est pour ça que je
parle d'une forme de
d'étirement et d'accroissement des
inégalités symboliquement avec une
humiliation plus forte de l'autre côté
mais vous êtes toujours les gars qui
bossent dans les abattoirs il y a
toujours les infirmières qui doivent
porter des corps à 3 heures du matin aux
urgences qui sont complètement saturés
vous avez toujours en fait des réalités
qu'on veut plus ou moins voir et que
parfois on veut toujours pas bien voir
je pense par exemple aux questions de
pénibilité liées à la santé mentale
hôpitaux psychiatrique par exemple qui
sont encore des sujets tabous avec des
formes de travail qui sont très mal
valorisées dans une société voire tabou
on pourrait parler des prisons on
pourrait parler ce que je veux dire donc
en fait l'ensemble du du corps social et
des différents types de travail métiers
associés s'étire en termes de
possibilités de potentialité avec d'un
côté des potentialités passe par la
technique par la technologie par la
science et notamment le numérique qui
augmente et qui sont même fascinantes
brisantes et de l'autre côté une forme
d'humiliation et de sous-valorisation et
ça je c'est un vrai défi pour les pour
les pouvoirs publics et les entreprises
aussi parce que ça veut dire avoir une
action beaucoup plus volontariste en
lien avec les corps intermédiaires et en
particulier avec les forces syndicales
pour mieux protéger et valoriser
les premiers de corvées et finalement
les oubliés de ce monde d'après quoi
parce qu'ils existent toujours en
réalité souvent on dit il y a plus de
classe ouvrière mais il y a une classe
ouvrière elle est peut-être plus
morcelée plus fragmentée moins visible
moins soudés moins tout ce que vous
voulez mais elle existe et on doit
toujours besoin de déplacer des colis
alors maintenant c'est peut-être je vais
vous choquer peut-être mais c'est
peut-être des migrants ubérisés qui qui
sont effectivement sans condition de
sécurité sociale etc mais est-ce que
c'est mieux mais c'est bien pire et
alors est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on se cache
les yeux et qu'on et qu'on ne regarde
pas ce sujet en face ou est-ce qu'au
contraire on les affronte donc il faut à
la fois tenir compte effectivement et
c'est plutôt positif des évolutions
liées à la technique sur des métiers qui
nous permettent de penser fortement les
attentes et de répondre aux attentes
notamment de la jeunesse sur le sens et
la qualité qu'on donne au travail sur
les nouvelles porosités entre mon neveu
professionnel personnel mais il faut
aussi en tout cas je crois que c'est le
rôle de la gauche pensez la protection
et la valorisation de celles et ceux
sans qui notre société elle fonctionne
pas merci alors Jean-Claude Mahy sur ce
je vais vous donner la parole également
Clara Gama on est là sur une question de
fond qu'est-ce que vous en pensez oui
d'abord je pense que ce n'est pas
question de dire il faut arrêter
l'informatisation ou les nouvelles
technologies après faut regarder comment
les choses sont gérés regarder s'il y a
des problèmes d'éthique etc c'est
autrement enfin vous avez plein de
métiers très pénibles qui ont disparu
grâce à la robotisation vous visitez une
une chaîne dans l'automobile aujourd'hui
vous voyez finalement peu de gens sur la
chaîne bon donc ça c'est permis par les
gains de productivité alors
automatisation alors c'est vrai que ça
peut générer
plus forte individuation des relations
sociales quand vous êtes en télétravail
vous êtes chez vous et donc mais toutes
les entreprises ont bien compris les
salariés le demandent aussi d'un moment
de collectif un moment donné et
indispensable et par rapport à ce que
disait Nicolas Mayer Rossignol ça c'est
un problème de fond la manière dont on
reconnaît en France comme ailleurs
d'ailleurs c'est pas spécifiquement
français
les métiers dit essentiel invisibles
dont on a qu'on ceux qu'on applaudissait
pendant la pandémie en fait depuis dans
les années 60 certains économistes
américains notamment ont considéré que
ces métiers de services alors partant
général d'une étude des métiers
artistiques bon et une mauvaise
extension ensuite considérer que c'était
des métiers improductifs donc étant des
métiers improductifs c'était les autres
qui devaient les rémunérer donc on a
on n'a pas rémunéré correctement tous
ces métiers depuis longtemps et c'est
encore vrai en France comme président de
la République hier dit ah il faudra
qu'on travaille sur les négociations de
salaire au niveau des branches et encore
des branches qui sont inférieures au
SMIC attendez moi je me souviens avoir
porté ce dossier en 2008 vous voyez on
est en 2023 et on avait à l'époque
obtenu une loi le ministre du travail
était Xavier Bertrand à l'époque mais
cette loi qui a été votée elle n'avait
jamais sorti parce que jamais eu les
décrets d'application voilà donc ça
c'est ça veut dire qu'on a toujours pas
réglé ce problème c'est un exemple un
exemple parmi d'autres donc ce sont des
gens qui eux ne peuvent pas
télétravailler qui ont des horaires des
difficultés dans dans leur métier et qui
en plus sont mal payés donc voilà ça ça
fait partie des des urgences et derniers
points je suis d'accord avec ce que vous
avez dit les catégories en emploi en
tous les cas c'est pas à ceux qui sont
les mieux formés c'est pas un ces
catégories difficiles qui ces métiers
existeront encore c'est entre les deux
quoi et là entre les deux sur les
syndicats qui se syndiquent le plus ces
catégories qui sont un peu en bas si je
puis dire de l'échelle ou ceux qui sont
plus avancés non je vais répondre
différemment si vous le permettez c'est
un jugement moral de ma part
ne juge là où là où la syndicalisation
est beaucoup plus difficile c'est par
exemple dans le monde des start-up ou
dans dans chez les Gafa voilà
effectivement là c'est une sadication
beaucoup plus difficile ce sont des
populations plus jeunes mais en plus qui
est en général et cette s'en sortir tout
seul s'il y a un problème il regarde sur
internet etc ils savent lire une
convention collective ou autre et donc
là ce sont des milieux qui sont à
conquérir pour pour le seigneur
des syndicats pour tenir compte de ces
évolutions
vous savez comme je dis souvent les
médical ce sont des exercices
démocratiques permanents donc c'est un
paquebot et un paquebot vous le faites
pas virer comme ça mais c'est de plus en
plus pris en considération par la
plupart des organisations aussi
réagir
à ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure le maire de
rond
parce que c'est tout à fait juste le
diagnostic qui est posé sur le fait que
les rémunérations qui sont les métiers
qui sont en fait essentiels et qui sont
les seuls qui resteront il faut pas se
tromper la digitalisation je sais pas si
vous avez entendu parler du jet de LGBT
ça permet de remplacer pas mal de gens
qui font du marketing qui font de la
communication etc donc les vrais métiers
qui resteront toujours c'est ceux qui
vont planter les patates c'est ceux qui
vont soigner les gens c'est ceux qui
vont porter les colis c'est ceux qui
vont faire marcher les trains etc ça
c'est des c'est des métiers réels ce que
je voulais simplement dire et que je
trouve extrêmement intéressant c'est que
vous avez toute une génération de jeunes
qui font partie a priori de l'élite
parce qu'ils ont fait des grandes écoles
etc qui vont dans ces métiers là
aujourd'hui qui font de la restauration
qui qui ouvre des usines pour fabriquer
des vêtements faits en France pour
fabriquer de la bière fait en France
pour fabriquer des t-shirts en France
etc et qui reviennent vers la petite
industrie ce qui est permis justement
par la technologie et qui
se réapproprie ces métiers et ils
mettent du savoir-faire qui est du
savoir-faire lié à leurs études et à
leurs compétences à la fois commerciales
internationale ils vont tout de suite à
l'international etc et donc il y a moi
l'espoir que je vois c'est que ces
métiers soient revalorisés grâce au fait
que aujourd'hui vous avez dans une
classe d'âge de jeunes qui sont a priori
ceux qui vont bâtir la France de demain
il s'intéresse à ces métiers parce que
justement c'est des métiers qui les
enracine qui leur donnent du sens et qui
parce que
on le dit pas assez est une réponse à
l'enjeu climatique qui est l'obsession
de la jeunesse et qui devrait être
l'autobsession à tous quand on parle de
la valeur travail on devrait la
revisiter sur la question enfin le
géologique nous le répète tous les jours
nous devons repenser notre système
économique notre système productif en
fonction de ce 1,5% ou 2 % climatique ce
que font les jeunes merci à David meurt
oui les
pouvoirs publics vont lancer le débat
sur les conditions de travail et sur la
formation je crois qu'il faut qu'il le
lance aussi sur les rémunérations et je
rejoins ce que disait Jean-Claude Mahy
il y a en France des pays des métiers
essentiels qui sont mal rémunérés et qui
sont mal rémunérés
par rapport aux autres pays européens
quand vous comparez les rémunérations
des enseignants et des soignants ils
sont beaucoup moins bien payés que dans
les autres pays européens qu'en
Allemagne un seul chiffre les
enseignants en débutant ils sont payés
40% de moins qu'en Allemagne par exemple
bon les soignants c'était également le
cas et d'où je crois les vraies
difficultés de recrutement qui existent
actuellement et qui peut et qui peuvent
de engendrer des situations tout à fait
dramatiques au niveau de l'enseignement
et puis de
des hôpitaux des EHPAD etc
concernant le salariat aujourd'hui qui
représente quand même
une part importante de l'éventail du
travail l'un des grands reproches qui
est fait sa vise le rapport hiérarchique
et de plus en plus contestée est-ce que
il y a une alternative à l'autorité de
Clara gaymartre en fait la question
c'est pas la question de l'autorité
c'est l'autorité qui est une autorité
hiérarchique et qui est pas une autorité
de compétences et aujourd'hui vous avez
des jeunes qui sont pour certains sujets
bien plus compétents que leur leur
supérieur et la plus grande la plus
grande qualité d'un dirigeant
aujourd'hui c'est l'humilité et
d'accepter qu'il ne sait pas tout et qui
ne peut pas tout la compétence du
dirigeant ce n'est pas le savoir c'est
de laisser ceux qui savent
exercer leurs compétences et avoir des
responsabilités et les respecter c'est
un changement de paradigme dans le
fonctionnement de l'autorité qui est
absolument clé votre avis à la ville
alors là dessus je partage complètement
cet avis nous avons en France dans les
entreprises j'ai une culture trop
hiérarchisée il faut revoir le
fonctionnement de ces entreprises et les
rendre plus horizontales plus
apprenantes c'est ce qui se passe dans
beaucoup d'autres pays européens et je
crois que là il y a un défi pour les
entreprises et le management oui
Jean-Claude Marie je suis d'accord
également jusqu'à dire Clara Games un
bon dirigeant c'est quelqu'un qui est
reconnu son autorité et reconnu et qui
sait s'entourer
oui alors Nicolas Meyer Rossignol sur
cette question de l'autorité est-ce
qu'il y a une alternative est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer à ce niveau
là ou pas changer d'ailleurs
je fais une suggestion mais qui n'est
pas si originale c'est c'est de
renforcer le rôle et la place que
peuvent
occuper les salariés dans la gouvernance
de l'entreprise ça évolué je veux pas
être manichéen mais reconnaissons que
par rapport à d'autres pays en Europe
par rapport à d'autres modèles de
société la France est peut-être pas le
plus en amont en avance pardon là dessus
à travers leur représentants les
syndicats à travers peut-être d'autres
formes dans les pactes de gouvernance
des entreprises en tout cas là dessus il
me semble qu'il y a quelque chose à
faire parce que là encore sinon on se
retrouve avec des situations qui peuvent
être vécues comme des humiliations
symboliques là en plus en faire de
manichéisme enfin vous avez vu la
récemment les annonces sur les
augmentations de salaires de telle ou
tel grand dirigeants de grandes
entreprises
bon il en a le droit c'est son autorité
mais ça relève plus d'une forme
d'humiliation d'autoritarisme et mettre
plus de gouvernance
avec plus de salariés dans cette
gouvernance ça me paraît un enjeu majeur
pour demain merci ecoutez il nous reste
quasiment le temps est complètement
écoulé j'ai peut-être le quelques
minutes très bref d'ailleurs pour vous
présenter une bibliographie alors un
livre
de Daniel SOSKIN un monde sans travail
bon ben vous voyez ce utopie de la fin
du travail
inspire et on verra ici comment
l'évolution notamment numérique
reconfigure le monde du travail alors
Nicolas Meyer Rossignol vous avez publié
avec
Guillaume Bachelet la gauche après la
crise quelle gauche et quelle crise en
deux mots parce que on peut se poser la
question
je dois à l'honnêteté de dire que ce
livre a été publié en 2010 donc avec un
peu dérision la gauche
écoutez en 2010 elle était en crise et
en 2012 elle a gagné en 2022-2023 la
gauche elle est toujours en crise en
2027 on verra c'est un signe de bonne
santé ça
vous savez ce que c'est allez je vais
vous répondre par le mot de Churchill
alors le vrai succès c'est d'aller
d'échec en échec avec toujours le même
enthousiasme merci alors Jean-Claude
Bailly vous avez publié un livre qui
s'appelle manif et chuchotement et alors
est-ce que vous continuez à chuchoter au
pral à l'oreille de d'Emmanuel Macron
je n'ai plus de contact avec lui depuis
que je suis parti et est-ce que vous
chuchotez à l'oreille des des
responsables de force ouvrières écoutez
moi je suis partisan je suis parti il se
débrouille s'ils ont besoin ils
m'appellent mais c'est pas moi
excusez-moi je vais être brutal je veux
pas être le vieux con qui donne ses
conseils ok on l'a bien compris alors
Clara Gemma vous avez publié avec
Bérénice bridge tête je sais pas si je
prononce bien
faut qu'on parle le monde a changé
franchement c'est de quel changement
vous voulez c'était un livre donc c'est
ma fille mais l'idée c'était de
d'évoquer le sujet du travail le sujet
du rapport à la consommation de tous les
grands thèmes qui ont porté mes 68 et
sur lequel les jeunes la jeune
génération est notamment les Millénium
recontestent tout notre façon il nous
juge très très sévèrement et donc
c'était un dialogue pour montrer que en
fait on s'aime beaucoup entre entre
générations mais en fait on ne se
comprend pas et on ne parle pas la même
langue et tout le sujet qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur la valeur travail sur
les retraites sur la façon d'appréhender
notre vie en société vient du fait que
la génération montante pense que nous
nous sommes complètement trompés et
c'est l'objet de ce livre merci alors je
voudrais rappeler j'ai cité l'étude
de l'Institut Montaigne sur les Français
le travail cette étude a été faite par
l'économie Bertrand Marino est-ce
qu'alainville meurt vous avez un livre
assuré
non enfin bon nous on a publié avec Jean
Hervé Lorenzi un livre il y a un an chez
Odile Jacob qui s'appelle la grande
rupture et derrière c'est l'idée qu'il
faut faire face à la fois la transition
démographique transition numérique et
puis la transition écologique dont on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais qui qui est
un défi considérable et concilier des
trois les trois défis c'est l'enjeu à
notre avis de ces 10 prochaines années
voilà bah il me reste à vous remercier
Madame merci messieurs d'avoir participé
à cette émission évidemment
elle n'est pas exhaustive sur la
question du travail n'aura l'occasion
d'en reparler merci à l'équipe d'elcp
qui a permis de la réalisation de cette
émission et avant de nous quitter je
voudrais vous laisser avec ce clin
d'oeil
de Simone de Beauvoir c'est par le
travail que la femme a en grande partie
franchie la distance qu'il a séparé du
mal c'est le travail qui peut seul lui
garantir une liberté concrète vous êtes
d'accord Clara GABA
il y a pas que le travail
[Musique]